التعرف على تفاصيلها اكثر معنى الياس
الياس كرام من القدس الياس اذا هناك
تطورات يعني رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول بانه كان يشارك جنود وحده
جفعاتي احتفالات الفصح ساعه اطلاق قضيتين
باتجاههم وقال بان الجيش الاسرائيلي تم
تفعيل سفارات الانذار في منطقه مفتوحه
بمستوطنات لديك تفاصيل اكثر كيف يتطور
الوضع في الميدان الان
نعم بالفعل جمال وكان هذا ربما في حوالي
الساعه التاسعه تقريبا عندما دوره الانذار
في منطقه مفتوحه في غلاف غزه تحديدا في
منطقه كيسوفيم الواقعه في وسط القطاع
والانباء الاوليه تتحدث عن سقوط قذيفتين
صاروخيتين اطلقتا من قطاع غزه واحده سقطت
في منطقه مفتوحه واخرى سقطت في داخل حدود
قطاع غزه الانباء الاوليه تتحدث على ان
القذيفه التي سقطت في داخل اسرائيل كانت
على مقربه من موقع عسكري كان يشارك فيه
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرتاليفي
جنود وحده دفعاتي في احتفالات عيد الفصح
اليهودي الذي يصادف هذه الليله لا اصابات
في هذه القذيفه لكن واضح بانها ربما تكون
مستهدفه بشكل عادي ومرتب لها ذلك ان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بامكانها ان ترصد
تحركات قاده